TO INVESTIGATE AND PROSECUTE
EVERY SINGLE PERSON WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT INVOLVED IN THIS.
HERE WITH REACTION, FORMER
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
JASON
JASO
JASON CHAFETZ AND SARAH, YOU
BROKE SOME NEWS TONIGHT.
THE MISSING FIVE MONTHS.
THAT IS HUGE TONIGHT.
>> IT'S HUGE NEWS.
IT FITS WITH WHAT OTHER FBI
AGENTS WERE TELLING ME WHERE
THEY SAID, LOOK, THEY CAN GET
THE TEXT MESSAGES.
THERE'S NO WAY -- THERE WAS A
FBI ARE EXPERTS AT GOING AFTER
CRIMINALS HIDING TEXT MESSAGES
AND ARE ABLE NO GET IT FROM THEM
AND IF THEY HAVE THE PHONES THEY
CAN GET IT AND IF THEY'RE IN THE
SERVER, THEY CAN GET IT.
THE QUESTION IS WHY DID THEY
RESPOND THAT WAY WITH THIS
TECHNICAL GLITCH?
I HAVE NEW NEWS, SEAN, I HAVE
BEEN TOLD BY MEMBERS IN CONGRESS
THAT THEY WILL RELEASE THAT
THAT THEY WILL RELEASE THAT MEMO
OUT AND GO TO THE PUBLIC.
>> Sean: THIS IS BIG NEWS BUT WE
TAKE IT A STEP FURTHER.
SEE MORE STEPS FROM LISA PAGE
AND PETER STRZOK.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> IF YOU EXTRAPOLATE THAT IS 65
TEXTS A DAY.
DID THEY HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THEIR JOBS AT THE FBI?
IT APPEARS ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THEY
HARBORED AN ANTI-TRUMP ANIMUS
AND UNABASHED ADORATION FOR
AND THEY WERE INVOLVED IN
CLEARING HILLARY CLINTON AND
LAUNCHING AN INVESTIGATION
AGAINST A POLITICAL CANDIDATE,
DONALD TRUMP, AND SPYING ON HIM,
IT'S AN ABUSE OF POWER, FELONY
CRIME AND YOU HAVE THE DOJ
TRYING TO COVER UP THE FOUR-PAGE
INTEL MEMO.
AS NIXON ONE SAYS IT'S NOT THE
CRIME IT'S THE COVER-UP.
>> Sean: LET'S GO TO THE NEW
DEVELOPMENT, SARA, YOU CAUGHT
THIS IN YOUR ARTICLE TONIGHT ON
SARACARTER.com AND JASON, THE
IDEA IS IF THE INVESTIGATION
LEADS TO IMPEACHMENT THERE'S NO
THERE, THERE.
F THE PRESIDENT AND IF I CAN GET
RID OF HIM AND THID
RID OF HIM AND THIS
RID OF HIM AND THIS W
RID OF HIM AND THIS WOU
RID OF HIM AND THIS WOULD
RID OF HIM AND THIS WOULD M
HISTORY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, SWEETHEART?
THAT'S WHAT HE'S SAYING TO HIS
LOVER.
>> THAT'S A GOOD SYNOPSIS BUT
THE ONLY THING I'D ADD IS THE
NEXUS TO BARACK OBAMA HIMSELF
COMMUNICATING UNDER AN ALIAS
USING AN ACCOUNT TO HILLARY
CLINTON WHO MAY HAVE BEEN
OVERSEAS PERHAPS IN RUSSIA ON A
NON-SECURE LINE WHAT WAS THE
WHO HAD NOT YET BEEN
INTERVIEWED --
>> Sean: 17 AND HILARY.
>> IF A JUDGE STARTED WRITING
HIS OPINION BEFORE HE HEARD
TESTIMONY -- COME ON.
JOHN RATCLIFF UNDER OATH ASKING
DIRECTOR COMEY WHEN YOU MAKE THE
DECISION.
THAT'S WHERE COMEY'S STRONGEST
LEGAL TROUBLES ARE.
RUSSIA THING BUT IF THIS CAN BE
HISTORIC, IF THIS IMPEACHMENT --
THESE -- F-HIM.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WROTE EACH
OTHER.
HAVE YOU STRZOK AND COMEY
WRITING THE EXONERATION AND THE
INSURANCE POLICY WITH PAGE,
WORKING AND NOT HAVE BEEN FIRED
AND WHY DID MUELLER PICK ALL
THESE PEOPLE AND A HAVEN'T
MENTIONED ANDREW WEISMAN YET.
>> THAT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
QUESTIONS FROM FORMER FBI FOLKS
SAYING, LOOK, HAVE WE DONE A
LITTLE BIT SPECK OF WHAT THESE
FOLKS DID, WE'D BE FIRED AND
REMOVED.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE ON THE
SEVENTH FLOOR.
WHY WOULD THE FBI PUT A GUY
HAVING AN AFFAIR.
AN AFFAIR AND TEXTING ON AN
UNSECURED LINE, HIS GOVERNMENT
ISSUED PHONE, OPEN FOR ANYONE TO
THEY MOVE HIM FROM OUT OF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL AND WE CAN'T GET
AN ANSWER TO WHY HE HASN'T BEEN
FIRED?
LOOK AT EVERYTHING THAT'S COME
FROM ANDREW WEISMAN ON SPECIAL
DOJ DOESN'T WANT THE FISA MEMO
OUT.
I AGREE CHAFFETZ.
>> Sean: STEVE BANNON TALKING IS
OLD NEWS TOO.
FROM ROBERT MUELLER'S OFFICE
BECAUSE THEY'RE UNDER FIRE AND
BECAUSE OF ALL THAT WE'RE
DISCOVERING HERE THEY KNOW THEIR
TIME IS UP?
SUBJECT OF THE INVESTIGATION,
DONALD TRUMP.
TRUMP CAN'T HIDE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
YOU HAVE COMMUNICATIONS TO
CONGRESS.
THIS SAY CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
THE PRESIDENT COULD BE HELD IN
FRONT OF A GRAND JURY.
SO TRUMP HAS TO RESPOND AND
TESTIFY.
THE ONLY QUESTION IS CAN HE
LIMIT THE SCOPE OF IT WHICH IS
ATTORNEY.
I HAVE YET TO SEE THEY CARE
ABOUT WINS AND LOSSES AND IT
COULD BE A TRAP AND HE'S A SMART
GUY.
WHEN HE NEEDS TO BE, I'VE READ
HIS DEPOSITIONS HE CAN BE
PRESIDENT -- I APPRECIATE HE
WANTS TO BE UP FRONT AND HONEST,
I WOULD NEVER EVER EVER IN A
MILLION YEARS ALLOW HIM TO GO
BEFORE THIS WITCH HUNT SPECIAL
COUNSEL --
>> BUT HE HAS NO CHOICE.
CAN'T INVOKE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
IT'S A LEGITIMATE
SPECIAL COUNSEL HE HAS
LEGITIMATE LEGAL ARGUMENTS?
>> BY MEETING WITH MUELLER YOU
ARE LEGITIMIZING HIS
INVESTIGATION WHICH IS
ILLEGITIMATE.
THERE HAS TO BE A STATED CRIME.
LOOK AT THE ORDER SIGNED BY
ROSENSTEIN TO MUELLER.
THERE'S NO STATED CRIME.
IT'S AN ILLEGAL INVESTIGATION
BUT THE PRESIDENT MAY HAVE NO
CHOICE.
>> Sean: LET'S GET YOUR TAKE ON
THIS, JASON CHAFFETZ, I WOULD
NEVER IN A MILLION YEARS.
I'D FIGHT THAT UP TO THE SUPREME
COURT ON THE GROUNDS, NUMBER
ONE, MUELLER'S TEAM IS CORRUPT,
IT WAS FOUNDED -- REMEMBER,
HILARY RIGGED THE PRIMARY.
STRZOK AND COMEY AND THEN THE
PHONY DOSSIER WAS A PREDICATE TO
CONSERVATIVE, REPUBLICAN,
MISUSE OF THE INTELLIGENCE AND
WEAPONIZING AGAINST THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> I THINK I WOULD DO WHAT YOU
SUGGESTED AND NOT DO IT BUT I
TELL YOU WHAT, DONALD TRUMP IS
UNLIKE ANYBODY I'VE SEEN BEFORE
AND THINK HE WANTS TO DO THAT
AND YOU LOOK AT WHAT DONALD
TRUMP JR. DID HE RELEASED
E-MAILS AND GAVE TESTIMONY.
THEY DO THINGS DIFFERENT.
ONE THING I HAVE TO ADD, WITH
STRZOK AND PAGE, WHY DO THESE
PEOPLE HAVE SECURITY CLEARANCES?
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A SECURITY
CLEARANCE, GUESS WHAT YOU DON'T
WORK AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
SECURITY CLEARANCE?
TAKE AWAY THAT SECURITY
CLEARANCE AND GET RID OF THEM.
THEY SHOULD BE FIRED AND WORKING
AND BEING PAID BY THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYERS.
>> Sean: SARA CARTER WE'LL GIVE
YOU THE LAST WORD THIS SEGMENT.
>> I SPOKE WITH A DEFENSE
ATTORNEY FAMILIAR WITH WEISMAN
AND MUELLER AND SAID THE
PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE TO BE CRAZY
TO FALL IN THEIR TRAP.
THIS IS WHAT THAT DO AND HAVE
DONE IN THE PAST AND WILL TRY TO
FIND ANYTHING AND WHY THEY WANT
TO QUESTION HIM.
SEAN, I DON'T KNOW THE LEGALESE
GREGG IS THE EXPERT BUT THAT'S
WHAT I WAS TOLD.
>> Sean: GREGG JARRETT.
>> BILL CLINTON TRIED HIS BEST
NOT TO TALK TO KEN STAR AND
NEGOTIATED SOME LIMITS ON HIS
TAPED INTERVIEW BUT IN THE END
HE HAD TO DO IT.
THERE'S NO LEGAL BASIS IN TRY TO
GO TO THE SUPREME COURT.
THE SUPREME COURT WILL KNOCK YOU
DOWN POLITICALLY.
IT WILL BE UGLY FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
HE HAS TO DO THE INTERVIEW.
>> Sean: BUT THERE'S A PRECEDENT
FOR THE TOPICS.
>> THE BILL CLINTON CASE.
>> Sean: IT CAN'T BE OPEN-ENDED.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
>> LIMIT THE SCOPE OF THE SCOPE.
BY THE WAY, FROM THE PRESIDENT'S
POINT OF VIEW IT'S SIMPLE.
I DIDN'T WORK WITH RUSSIANS OR
INCLUDE IN TERMS OF OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE I'M ALLOWED TO FIRE